look at that kitchen guarded by Bruce  brown loop it for the lane comes in it  goes like Lieber with a quick shot Lucca  down the length floaties gone off what  double budget it goes and it's six to  two that's a triple that's six to five  Dallas porzingis from way outside buries  it Andre with four Pistons trailed by  two porzingis Rises and triples again  and it goes underneath the screen that  means you're wide open  there's dodge it with Derrick Rose  trailing this folks through the legs  from behind don't know exactly what it  did for him but it was certainly pretty  hard away call for the foul run at the  top of the show crystal kadachan lead  the Mavericks to a 15-point lead the  Pistons take timeout  the problem here is i think that  porzingis had been stymied  or Zuka screens rolls to the raft place  it in bumped and fouled dust over us  five to play here in the third  that [ __ ] squares up a gun it go